I
Fred I change the title to this is not
the synthesizer we're going to go
through a bunch of differences actually
are real this is a synthesizer but
instead korg ms-20 was released by the
court company in nineteen seventy eight
at the time for this a valley was
considered fairly compact programmable
extensible and here at all the records
from nineteen seventeen nineteen eighty
of even today very popular machine and
restated yourself that if you know which
are listening tours it's recognizable it
was designed to replace this that
wasn't portable right had a lot of
issues with communication protocol haha
and but also had the same inherent
design and that design is a modular Ella
so within this thing Hannah lock
yourself remain de MIDI out that they
added to the reissue this year the one
goes like I was beheaded no chips
resistors capacitors in all organized
and was analyzed eight modules are
basically pure functional and take input
you have output to have no side effects
it can be your clothes into very
complicated sounds that soon program is
called programs programs can be shared
over the internet but pieces of paper
they they will right now they scribble
and panty what you gave to the student
so I was lucky enough two thousand one
working at recording studio DNA
according to do and this was something
that very confident we would program in
this section and makeup patches and you
can look at
Patrick look like here and then we would
share that this information was shared
between people sometimes like that's
great scribbles we could write a
language it's over hand you some notes
here's dispatch to try it out but at a
score I started learning coder I thought
that this almost encoder machine just
combining functions and it's very
functional I can explain
worship would not like really not what
you should rest is what most efficient
work as you have emotional pieces which
is what more hair appeals reversed if
not religiously observant
I'm gonna play it off but I wanted to
show you an intro to how this program is
working for them so solve a the most
like that right it's a and this gene has
to us letters they can generate salt
lake forest where we ain't noise and he
chased me with its own so he do black
ball solid 100 would be a frequency of
100 generates all these and those and it
also don't do much else but these are
encoding a around here is 440 so
somewhere around there that would be
like so yeah it's all wave as frequency
competition so sound but yeah this all
wave at this frequency is full body and
the next one is called an overtone it
has an attached to one over N and
descending all the way down and each of
these can be proposed from silence but
indicates the Soviet you can just have
any program work electronics that will
generate then shake specials
git add two souls together so that's one
that's to hear the overtones second one
is quieter that's to add together so
they both oscillators come into the air
then it comes with a derp so it's the
same thing as it kind of closure boost
dialect plus two brief because I'm
filter theater just models and filters
take this whole composition of sound
goes out here and subtract next
subtractive synthesis basement we have
all these frequencies if you apply a
filter the filter has a parameter two
primers cutoff and resonance be cut up
to be at what frequency here start
cutting and residents would say that
cutter producing boost things up a lot
it has very unique sound to use both
high-pass filter suggesting the opposite
we start walking over the only take out
the low frequencies you leave still has
a president and yes we have high and low
so now you have four things that we've
seen so you can start to do some
moderate more complicated you can add to
solving apply a public 200 we can put
the resonances value to 0 1 generally
they're pulling back frequencies trend
line over no
there's a high example so again the same
function in there no I actually yeah the
last thing is it humble to shape the
amplitude of the sound so you can hit
make a very punchy sound you may just
happen to k's for all time high
amplitude some are here but a boat's
here
attack okay sustained release so here I
have a long release and again that's
just a function that your input signal
is passed through now maybe we're
getting a little more complicated we
would create an envelope with attacks
you get needs to stay and release we
would ask enough or both pass filters
this from adam to solve pretty much but
that's what we just heard this way those
are like location of how to communicate
hatches programs on this box last thing
is an LFO that's a low frequency
oscillator so there are things that you
can hear 16,000 currently down below CP
maybe a below that is subsonic and here
but it's still waves and we can use
those to control other rooms you can
feel them that's for sure and sevilla
have low frequency oscillators here that
means to change
pretty much the architect for every
synthesizer out there this is not
actually corresponding output but it's
real and for all so what I want to do
today is build this in an overt or
covert own is a closure by Drake or
working with synthesis modules both by
sam Mary it's amazing his video on it is
here I would even try to do that in just
as I saw that before it very pissed off
in addition he's really great the
library is just incredible under worker
said it provides a lot of people when
they improvise these versions of these
compartments so you can instantiate
these things you can rather than using
very much same language it's built on
synthesis engine called super collider
which I played around the studio conform
and to get too distracted when I was
playing that directly but an overtone
and closer together it's very fluid both
people kind of approach to building so
at some point trying to set this up we
ran into it ad issues we have this
projector but on the back screen is this
iPad a reference at compile-time 900mm
that's running application called touch
auskick which is basically a client that
sends UDP messages to a URI and we can
actually get those and chambers inside
knows my later let's start with basics
of overcome overtone you interact within
the rebel for the most part I've already
initiated
or come loaded hopefully it's a bit
messed up but that's okay Nexus but you
can do really simple things demo just
the three parameters that that one says
it time on three seconds place out so I
don't have to stop there's a sign and
this is a spectrum air and much like Lee
showed that solve a picture earlier just
little actually produce the picture of
all the frequencies that are you sound
but so sine wave at 100 or 440 operators
day just has the one there is the f-14
you'll see also see that start adding up
silence sound change may also see should
seek repeat so there they are those are
the three we can build saws and square
the waves that we got here I just
stacking outside and if you look at this
demo here the basically take 1 100 I add
up sideways that weakens their 100 times
what are we all ready over here and I'm
going to map that the sign house and I
must do it
sounds like solved he cuts off at the
end there because I did power go to the
400 then it would there be more
frequently but it's expensive and takes
a while to start so just show up for
example when I cup you do the same thing
with a square wait for the square wave
you actually every other female in the
hollow sound food that's you have every
other Oklahoma's represent there's a
problem with doing this so is it it's
very expensive to stack of all the
signers to look them up and look up
table degenerate yourself you can get
amazing clarity if you do without
environment but it's much cheaper faster
and actually louder more obnoxious to
just do so is directly in square roots
directly and start manipulating them and
subtract as an example of this is
smaller native work but you could just
generate a string of ones and zeros and
that would generate the swirl and that's
incredibly cheap leading to something
like that and his were connected to an
alpha phone without with Jennifer square
wave that's a lot how the oscillator
that are built in these sins are built
as if they use passively but see so in
the subtractive synthesis just take the
oscillator that overtone the supervisor
provide we get the same sound
go ahead in your stack sideway burden
so similar sound cheaper and that's it
so once we have these things start
playing around you add add them up just
take your add anything else doing with
you can multiply them in just minutes
just like I played the two so it's over
here but because it's a programming
language is easy just three or four
cheese that says take 30 always in 2 24
48 acres scale them down by point 33 so
they don't get too low and must be the
same thing with the larger sequence
which is using 02 there hi Rach so now
we play around the filters you start to
do the same thing so I take these
pre-salt now filtering out at 220 / so
to speak here a black / see that in the
spectrogram they have about 22 28 out if
you're the thumbnail yeah so that
distortion effects or nothing he'll make
it so there's three but we can do now is
start to actually control this thing
control the filter
is also my favorite then it actually
makes me happy for I not you that sound
now we do the same with I fast builder
now this is the real hear this oh okay
that's all the modules they're not very
useful unless there's way to communicate
between here we have the control voltage
for the ball like I mentioned before
there's actually bolted going across the
wire and then that's it doesn't scale
really well I think it's really hard to
send more than two signals over the wire
but is it both going to require we don't
have that here what we do have similar
so there is a blessing system which I
called attachment system and overcome
supervisor that you can use to create
each dimension that's what we've got to
do here so I create a hash table
basically and I give it less that it's
going to be over and I have a sin that
takes it out put the outpost and its
frequency five but then where to sign
off the favorite for this is my low
frequency oscillator so I'm going to
create basically one deep moment here it
just generates a low frequency album and
I'm going to try to patch I look like
the low frequency oscillator to another
instrument by simple salt
and that thing takes an input just cut
off must push effectively like taking
one of these cables taking them out of
the low frequency oscillator actually in
to pacifica so under low frequency
oscillator because all this is done with
server-side connected let's troll this
thing
start getting into frequency the
dictionary correction cheetah sound
she's alone
yep oh I get all three cut yeah those
are other parameters and they become to
you put forth and create a bus ottoman
set other I will to them now they
started getting crazy doesn't really
have those building blocks she abilities
come to build this thing game software
so what I do is show them so this will
get a little more comfy but all the
basics are here what I'm going to try to
do is fill in the missing piece here so
we have this touch-ups you can also see
the pack the rebel is nice but rubble is
not as interactive as i would like to be
so i can use the touch a sketch to the
simulate peace talks it's really cool
epic used to control a lot of things on
patrol necessarily but to control
surface were many beautiful then I try
and do the Coachman's that's really
extensible on it
don't move on
Blue Hole
Oh
the creative design and trainers in one
word level generally holds three are
large / doing that work domestic 07 / w
it doesn't matter of who we are doing it
forever to this is the modeling industry
on familiar w
it has three quarter net has start my
new model s 1 on yahoo answers I'll
Andreozzi I'm us to each of these names
around Iraq so cool i may be that nearly
10 miles later pretty much that's the
same so into the second semester one of
her way to my heart yeah so critical
here with rigor by this game those are
cut out into love 00 yeah we'll move
directly on them along the way i did
notice it is very ugly than a little
longer than yourself have them send out
it was near
we have
what
funding will do then you start laying
for example they include for here
interesting arrival is working an angle
that's right step 512 interstate
basically has similar control to this
with my resume our sound music we go
some control this thing it's not going
to work there is that a good easy to my
server here and that's controlling the
release time to level the race car
repair that know a good long
now there's a tough only favorite sound
I'm just listening to residents for
hustling if you're a really high
frequencies around the little spot here
military never
I insisting has a little ones to get
engage and disengage your Bible is your
and moving safe effective boy is capable
go ahead if you're fighting to stay five
that's what good police think round play
them
cool that's that that kind of a version
of that but this is my one takeaway this
is not really very good summation there
really a problem yea big waves don't
send anything similar to me they're not
Richard you're not as a dynamic garage
chunji know the controls are there
keyboard and I would never be able to
use visiting a live performance and we
built you visited this didn't just stand
up to credible audience or the sounds
January here to start right now and
that's why people still use the Corbin
is fun today whether you will be around
a thing for a long time but that's my
settlement oh so it is incredibly useful
playbill here so first it's really fun
but I can model I've now developed a
framework for every model in the
subtractor said this is I can model in
town the night here and start to compose
new sounds into their then pull on it a
little something a little more music so
I call this a cell phone 8 way home now
let go casio to ban that used to like
making out build something outside jump
off of here and start to build something
crazy and
free for what's going to a lost
connection to this guy a lifetime the
wealthy and glue that will still make
those we're going to try to get on the
base budget but it's okay alright so I
mean has your column what we can do now
is use these subtractive synthesis it
gives and modules developing SMS pony
certainly things like kick drums or
snare drum or at least in or even a
symbol hi hat as many instruments as we
take for me so we take the same timing
bus setup they use before and if Ella p
same bus since my ability to sound then
I start building new since not my damn
is plenty still here but different the
first one just a basic sauce and I
didn't really find to do much so it
takes us all wait we get to the cut up
and residents that you stroke and
replies ate the decay which is as simple
or so it's just an attack ok very
actually yeah so that's it basic so you
do the same thing to the square wave add
that and that's in my toolbox now now I
have to sense that I can play with there
are a lot of people to do this and it's
a lot of fun I Cooper I want a ritual
package you modified it to work in my
sequence or in winter and then played
around it why I let them working with
this in the rebel if you take a starting
point button all the parameters here
actually have two lon plane so this
instrument would only really be useful
for me is not everything to change or
not everything's a crime but it's how I
which is a copy and paste way of working
that I felt if I ever going to committed
you develop bro is really just for me to
bear out that is TV for your grade is my
favorite aged woman ever this is another
we were simulation with it sounds kind
of here there's a drum machine called
the 909 that I used to play loudly and
this is an emulation of that again they
hate drama video makers the bass drum
that a mic this is a really kind of
messy kick drum that is made from again
thus always has been filtered out and I
had some white noise of optimal so to
think of a head they use it from limb
there's a little bit of percussive sound
which is also a deep resonating wave set
that's the model that I have a business
and built here asaram's actually exactly
like me pick from they're almost the
same thing dish is that this tone is a
lot less so snare still at the tone
there's a lot of north so I add noise
and give it a moment a movie theaters
that's a Sarah this one was a little bit
tougher they want to make a sound symbol
make the sound of a symbol they're
taking square waves and over moms they
just don't make any sense and adding
them up together now it has very good
Alex I'm you think a square wave and
then do the sounds to be combined with
its various cording that could be what
your model of the Civil it works it will
serve kind of anger but kind of not you
have raised
okay now I have all these things and
probably try to play poker I lost
connection to this
get sassy forward home start up
if you get it in a couple seconds of his
buddy under troffer and other equally as
fun that I've been stated rebel all
right so our goal should load will see
it over the second
stick around
that's all there that thing itself is
really a lot doesn't it sounds kind of
hokey ever live cashio it's the it's the
beginning of what this time used to make
songs all the basic fundamentals are
there it build on that overtone
amazingly powerful
or fun to bring those two things
together and sit around with this that's
it that's all I have there's a get home
NYC seal j algorithms versus their micc
LJ PETA that you can clone play around
these things set it out fix some
problems yeah it's all just very much
like a note that like I think a rebel
should be in this very interactive
it's a time of any questions